Yep.
>> Um,
so we're talking about the Trinity
today.
>> Uh, sure. Jesus is the most high God. If
you disagree with that, then
[clears throat]
>> I do. I believe he's just a man that is
a prophet.
>> Okay. What's your religion?
>> Uh, Islam.
>> Islam. Okay. What makes you think that
he's just a mere man?
>> Do you want to refer to scripture or do
you want to refer to
>> scripture?
>> Scripture. Okay, great. Um, do you want
to pull up Isaiah 2:4?
>> Okay.
Isaiah chapter 2, verse 4.
All right. So, it says,
I'm going to read in a few verses a bit
above for context. Okay.
>> Of course.
>> All right. So, the word of Isaiah
>> Awesome. The word that Isaiah, the son
of Amos,
saw concerning Judah and Jerusalem, it
shall come to pass in the latter days
that the mountain of the house of the
Lord shall be established in the highest
of mountains and and shall be lifted up
above the hills, and all the nations
shall flow to it, and many peoples shall
come and say, "Come, let us go up to the
mountain of the Lord, to the house of
the God of Jacob, that he may teach us
his ways, and that we may walk in his
paths. For out of Zion shall go forth
the law and the word of the Lord from
Jerusalem. He shall judge between the
nations and shall decide disputes for
many peoples and they shall beat their
swords into pler plowshares and their
spears into pruning hooks. Nation shall
not lift up sword against nation,
neither shall they learn war anymore.
>> You'd agree. You do agree he would be
Jesus
when he's coming, right?
>> It says it says God. So if you agree
that Jesus is God, then sure.
>> Well, you would agree that. So this
would count in you believing that this
>> Jesus.
>> So you you agree that this is explicitly
it says that it's God that's going to be
judging between the nations, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. However, I do also agree that you
would believe that this would be Jesus
as well in this.
>> That's agreeable, right?
>> Sure. I mean, I have no problem.
>> So, you believe that Jesus uh stopped
all wars because it does say
>> not yet.
>> Yeah, not yet. He will.
When
>> will that happen?
And when he comes,
he's already came.
>> No, he has another coming, brother. Even
even you believe he has another coming.
>> I do.
>> Yeah. So that's when this will be
fulfilled.
>> Okay. Um do you want to talk about uh
the logicality of eternity? That's where
I have more of my arguments in.
>> So you agree that the Bible teaches
Jesus is God?
the Bible itself. Yes.
>> I appreciate your honesty, man. That's
go. That's good.
Okay. So, what um when it when it comes
to like uh Jesus being God, you don't
you don't believe that it makes sense in
regards to him sharing the same essence
as the father and the spirit?
>> Can you say that one more time? I'm
sorry.
You don't you don't think it makes sense
for Jesus to share the same essence as
the father and the holy spirit?
>> That's correct. It makes no sense to me
at all.
>> Okay. And you're and you're saying that
taled makes logical sense.
>> Yes. That there's one God. That
absolutely makes more sense than there
being
Yeah.
>> being what?
>> Than there being Jesus as God while in
human flesh and all that. That makes no
sense.
>> Wait. So tell because I'm confused
because obviously the the trinity is the
belief that there's one God. Okay. So if
you're saying
>> the trinity is more than just belief of
one God though. It's a belief that Jesus
is also a god who is human.
>> No, not a god.
>> The god that's human
>> that took on flesh at at a point in
time.
>> See, that makes no sense. How do I know
that?
Why would God why would God limit
himself to be hungry
>> and do things that is something he
doesn't do that go against his nature?
>> That's a good question. That's a good
question. So I would I would also
counter and I'm I'm just going to make
sure that we have equal scales. Okay. I
would say that taled isn't just
believing that Allah is one God, but
it's believing and affirming all of his
attributes that are completely unique to
him and that come together to make Allah
who he is. Is that accurate?
>> It's accurate in the sense of yeah, his
names and his personalities and his
Yeah, I agree that there's one God. Now,
with this idea of God limiting himself
to endure or experience things that he I
mean, you know, doesn't have to um like
why would he do that? I would say that
the easy answer is love. Because God
loves his creation, he would he would do
such things like limit himself for a
while to accomplish whatever he wants to
accomplish. You don't think that God can
do that or would do that?
Um
I think he would do that but not in the
way that the Bible says he did.
>> Ah okay. So even you believe that for
the sake of his love for his creation
that he would limit himself to
accomplish his will for his creation
that he wants to accomplish. But you
just don't believe that he would do it
in the way that the God of the Bible
did. Why not?
Because it
it makes no sense to me that God would
kill someone to forgive people. Would
you kill your son to forgive people?
>> You you mean put like sacrifice himself
to forgive people?
>> Right. Why can't you just forgive people
in general?
>> Because well, let me ask you this. Um if
I stole something and I ended up in a
courtroom and they got me on camera, I'm
guilty. I'm guilty. I stole. But the
judge just forgives me and lets me go.
Would he be just?
>> No. That's not justice,
>> right? So, if we even know that an
earthly judge would be corrupt if he
just let our crime go and just forgave
us, how much more just and holy and pure
is the judge of the universe? He can't
just let our sin go and just say, "Oh,
you're forgiven. You're good to go." No.
sin crime has to be dealt with. It has
to be punished.
So instead of having us take on the
punishment that we rightly deserve, he
comes and takes on flesh, represents
mankind,
and takes on the punishment that we
deserve so that we don't have to because
he loves us that much.
I mean, do you have to commit suicide to
forgive people?
>> Would you say
>> God is also all forgiving? Correct.
>> No.
>> If No, he's not all forgiving.
>> No. No. If he was all forgiving, then
there wouldn't be a hell, would there?
There's a there's there's a He draws a
line. God has his boundaries.
He's not all forgiving. He is very
forgiving.
The most forgiving. He's not all
forgiving. He doesn't forgive
everything. When you you you sin against
God and you live in that sin, you will
go to hell.
That's it. Right. Even Islam teaches
this. So, but um
um when it comes to you said something
about like suicide, I would say that
it's it's it's sacrifice instead of
suicide, right? Because he gives his
life. Now, here's another thing, too. He
says,"No one can take." This is what
Jesus says in John chapter 10. Matter of
fact, I'll just I'll I'll read it. Let
me go there real quick for you.
It's pertaining to this idea of giving
his life. In John 10:1 17,
he says this,
"For this reason the Father loves me
because I lay down my life that I may
take it up again.
No one takes it from me, but I lay it
down of my own accord. I have authority
to lay it down and I have authority to
take it back up again. This charge I
have received from my father. So Jesus
says that no one can take his life from
him. No one can actually kill him,
right? But it's he who lays down his
life on his own authority and he can
take his life back up from the dead.
So, it's sacrifice. If you give your
life, like you you would say if you were
to jump in front of a bullet to save a
friend, is that suicide or is that
sacrifice?
>> Both.
Absolutely. It's both. Is your
Oh,
what happened?
Your camera just went out and I don't
see you and I don't hear you.
Sorry, man. Uh, I accidentally clicked
out. You would say it's both.
>> Absolutely.
>> Why would you say it's both?
>> Cuz you're you're doing something that's
going to guaranteed to kill you or at
least harm you. Mostly going to kill
you.
>> Mhm.
>> But you're also doing it for the
betterment. So, it's both.
>> So, so would
>> you know, you know, you're going to die.
>> Yeah. Wouldn't Wouldn't that make uh
make it a make it different from
suicide? Is the intent behind it that
you're giving your life up for another?
I I would say that intention matters
when we're defining these both actions.
Right.
>> Hang on. Let me see if there's a
definition of suicide.
>> Okay.
I mean, yeah. The definition of suicide
is death caused by self-directed danger
in behavior.
>> Yep. The act of an instance of ending
one's own life voluntarily and
intentionally an action that ruins
destroys one yada yada yada. Mhm.
Someone who dies by or attempts Why
would they Why would they use the the
word in the definition? That don't make
no sense.
Okay, now let's see. Sacrifice.
[clears throat]
Sacrifice.
Sacrifice
the act of giving up or losing something
of value for the sake of something else.
See, for so with the definition of
suicide, it wasn't for the sake of
something else. The difference that
makes suicide different from sacrifice
is that sacrifice is doing it for the
sake of something else.
Make sense?
>> That makes some sense. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So intention matters I would say.
So that's why we call it a sacrifice
rather than a you know suicide.
It's pretty loving, right? That's the
gospel. That God would sacrifice himself
for his creation that is way beneath
him.
An action that doesn't befit him. He's
way above that, but yet he still did it
anyway because he loves us. That's huge.
You know, the Quran, you know, Islam
teaches the opposite.
Instead of Allah stepping in and giving
his life for us, what he does for the
Muslims is that he replaces a Jew, I
mean he gives a Jew and a Christian in
the Muslim place. Instead of Allah
stepping in the Muslim place himself and
taking on their sins and you know making
them righteous, Allah will put their
sins on a Jew or a Christian.
>> You want to show me a verse or a hadith
for that one?
>> Yes sir. Yes sir. This will be in Sahi
Muslim
2767A
and a few others.
Now, this right here I would say is
crazy.
So, even in Islam, it doesn't teach that
Allah just forgives you. That he just
>> finger screen.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm about to pull it
up in a second.
It doesn't show that he just forgives
you because he doesn't. He puts your
sins on someone else.
Uh 27.
All right, here we go.
Boom. Boom. All right, let me get to it
real quick.
2767A.
So, in Islam, here it is.
Whoops. [laughter]
Rookie mistake. Here
we go.
There we go. You can see it.
>> Yes, sir.
>> All right. Yep. Sah Muslim 2767A.
Abu Musa reported that Allah's messenger
said, "When it will be the day of
resurrection, Allah would deliver to
every Muslim a Jew or a Christian and
say that is your rescue from hellfire."
So we, the Jews and the Christians,
we're your saviors [laughter]
on judgment day. Isn't that crazy?
How is this just?
What's your thoughts on this, brother?
>> Not sure.
>> Well, I can tell you my thoughts, man. I
think that this is, if we're being
direct and we're being honest, I think
this is straight up evil. How in the
world, number one, can mere human beings
who also have their own sins
carry the sins of others?
They can't. That's impossible. It
doesn't work.
Secondly,
why is it that Allah is using mere human
beings and placing replacing them with
other human beings to save the other
ones but leave these ones in hellfire?
What?
Why doesn't he just come himself,
represent the Muslims himself
and the Jew and Christian if he loves
them, represent everyone, represent all
mankind and be the rescue from hellfire
himself. That's Jesus. That's what Jesus
does. Jesus
represented mankind himself. Represented
all of us. Muslims, Jews, Christians,
Buddhists, Hindus, doesn't matter. He
represented all mankind by taking on
flesh and putting all the sins of the
world on himself
and giving up his life for us.
Christ is our rescue from hellfire in
Isl in Christianity.
a Jew and a Christian is your rescue
from hellfire in Islam.
Um here's another one that says this. If
we just scroll down to the next one, it
says Abu Ba reported on the authority of
his father that Allah's apostle said,
"No Muslim would die, but Allah would
admit in hisstead a Jew or a Christian
in hellfire."
To prevent the Muslim from going to
hell, he's going to replace him with a
Jew or a Christian in hell so that the
Muslim doesn't have to be in hell.
Umar
uh Umar bin Abd Al alaziz took an oath
by one besides whom there is no god but
he thrice that his father had narrated
that to him from Allah's messenger.
So
do you think that this is uh that this
is just and all forgiven?
>> Not quite.
>> Not quite. Not quite.
Does this make sense? Does this make
more sense than God himself coming and
representing mankind and doing it
himself?
Uh, the way you frame it a little bit
kind of
it makes more sense the way you frame
it, but the way I'm seeing it right now
is
God came as a human, which God isn't a
human, he's God. And that's kind of
where I'm at with that.
Well, God can come as a human without
ceasing to be God. But he can come as a
human because he's God. He could do
that. He's God. So he could take on a
human nature, walk amongst us, teach us,
live amongst us, dwell with us in a way
that doesn't destroy us because of his
glory and infinite power. He can veil
himself in flesh.
He can conceal his divine glory and his
nature in flesh
and walk amongst us and give his life in
that flesh on our behalf.
That's why you see Jesus say things
like, "No one can take my life from me.
You can't you can't kill me. I lay my
own life down and guess what? I'll take
it back up again because he's God.
That makes perfect sense that he can do
that if he's God, right?
>> Sure, God can do anything.
>> Yeah, he can do it all. This ain't this
ain't The Bible says he says that he is
he says, "I am God Almighty. Is there
anything too hard for me?" Obviously,
it's a rhetorical question. There's
nothing too hard for him. There's
nothing he can't do. And there's nothing
no length that he w would would not go
to to save
his creation, to save his loved ones.
The Bible says that he made us in his
image and in his likeness, that he gave
us rulership and dominion and authority
over the earth. That we are
representatives of God and he loves us,
you know. So, and watch this. Watch what
watch what uh Jesus says even about
giving your life. How he talks about
this um what verse is that? That's in
John.
What verse is that, guys? Where he talks
about no greater love has no Oh, here it
is. Oh, yeah. Here it is. John 15. Oh,
100's already on it. John 15:13. Watch
what Jesus says here, man.
John 15:13. Well, actually, let's do
let's do start 12. This is my
commandment that that you love one
another as I have loved you. He's
talking to his disciples.
Love one another as I have loved you.
And he says, "Greater love has no one
than this, that someone lay down his
life for his friends.
You are my friends if you do what I
command you.
See, see how see how how God talks about
us, how he's involved with us,
that he will come and he will
participate in the greatest love ever to
be performed. The the the greatest act
of love that you can perform for someone
is giving your life for them, stepping
in front of that bullet for them,
risking your life for them. That's the
greatest show of love that anyone can
show.
And God did it.
So this is Christianity, bro. This is
the gospel.
Now, how do you know that Prophet
Muhammad isn't the prophet with all the
good things he's done? For example, he's
risked to death. Why would he do that if
he's just teaching something false for
his own measures?
>> He risked death. He risked losing
family. He's done so many great things
that, you know, obviously wouldn't have
benefited him in any way, but he still
kept doing it.
>> Let me show you something.
>> I'll show you why.
I disagree that Muhammad did a lot of
great things.
Now I don't think that he didn't do he
never did anything good but he did a lot
of bad things and his prophethood
benefited him greatly. He received a lot
of benefits when it came to him being a
prophet of Allah. Let me show you one of
them. Um let's go to chapter number 33.
Now remind me how many wives is a Muslim
allowed to have?
>> Four. And the prophet was able to have
five.
>> Oh, no. He wasn't able to have more than
five. Matter of fact, Muhammad had a I
think they say at the at the minimum
nine. I've heard 11 as well, but um he
had he had he had way more than five.
>> It's not all at once.
>> Yeah, it is. There's there's [laughter]
there's a hadith that talks about how
Muhammad slept with all of his wives in
one night.
Yeah, there's a lot of Hades. There's a
lot of crazy Hades with details like
that. But, um, what's the verse I'm
looking for? Okay. Uh, 3350, I think.
Now, watch this.
Um,
okay, I'll share my screen. This is
chapter 33:50
of the Quran. Chapter 33:50.
Oh prophet, indeed we have made lawful
to you your wives to whom you have given
their due compensation and those your
right hand possesses from what Allah has
returned to you of captives
and the daughters of your paternal
uncles
and the daughters of your paternal aunts
and the daughters of your maternal
uncles and aunts who immigrated with you
and and a believing woman if she gives
herself to to the prophet if the prophet
wishes to marry her.
This is only for you
excluding the other believers.
This is a benefit that only Muhammad
gets. He gets to have as many as he
wants. What whatever believing woman
offers herself to him, he can he can
take her if he wants. all the uh all his
cousins,
all his all his first uh first cousins.
He can have them all if he wants. We
certainly know what we have made
obligatory upon them concerning their
wives and those their right hand
possess.
Uh but this is for you in order that
there will be upon you no discomfort.
You see that Allah's making sure that
Muhammad has no discomfort that he's
perfectly comfortable above the
believers and ever is Allah forgiving
and merciful.
You mean to tell me that Muhammad isn't
getting benefits man from this?
>> I you these benefits that Allah gives
him are because of the other
discomforts that he does have such as
risking his life.
>> Nope. I didn't say that. I don't say
none of that.
That's a scholarly opinion on this
stuff.
>> Yeah, I would I would say I would
challenge that scholar to show me where
the Quran explains that because the
Quran never says that. Um, what we see
here is that because he is the prophet,
he is getting Now, mind you, Muhammad's
risking his life. Aren't the Muslim men
risking their lives as as well when they
go into battle for the for the sake of
Allah? Aren't they being martyed for the
sake of Allah as well?
>> They are being martyed for the sake of
Allah as well. Yeah. So then why don't
they get these benefits? They're risking
their lives. They're they're
experiencing discomforts of traveling
away from their wives and going out in
the desert to battle and to camp and and
to be gone from home for months at a
time, weeks at a time, struggling with
food and water on the road. You know,
they're experiencing all of this
discomfort. Why can't they have mult
have as many wives as they want? Why
only Muhammad?
You see what I'm saying?
So, a a scholarly opinion that just
throws that out there. Remember, just
because a scholar says it, my brother,
it doesn't mean that we should blindly
take it. Let's critically think about
what they're telling us. That just
because someone gives an interpretation
does not mean that that interpretation
is valid. We have to critically analyze
what they're saying with the text and
let's see if it matches. So with that
scholarly interpretation, that's that's
bullet. That that that don't make no
sense. That's that's bull crap,
you know. Um
the war booty as well. Muhammad got more
of the war booty, the war loot than uh
than the Muslims. He got to get extra.
He got to get extra. Um,
>> you going to bring that up?
>> Yeah.
Let's see here. I want to get the full
context.
Let me see.
So, fear Allah and a man that between
you and obey Allah.
Let's see. The believers are only those
yada yada yada.
I know it's somewhere in chapter eight.
Let's
see.
Those are the believers truly for them.
What's what's what's the verses uh about
the war, booty, guys? I could have sworn
it was chapter eight that talk that
where it talks about the division of the
of the loot when it comes to the war. I
know it's in chapter eight. I'm I'm
having a brain fart right now.
I might have to do a a video later to
show you what I'm talking about,
[snorts] but right now I'm having a
brain fart.
They ask you about the bounties of war.
The bounties is ah here it is.
Look at this.
This is chapter 8 verse one.
It says
they ask you, oh Muhammad, about the
bounties of war. Say
the bounties
is for Allah and the messenger.
So fear Allah and amend that which is
between you and obey Allah and his
messenger if you should be believers.
The bounties is for Allah and his
messenger. What bounty does Allah get
from the war? That all goes to Muhammad.
He gives a double portion. Let's see.
They're saying verse 412. Let's see.
and know that anything you obtain of war
booty then indeed for Allah is oneif of
it and for the messenger
and for
near his near relatives and the orphans
the needy and the traveler if you have
believed in Allah and in what and in
that which we sent down to our servant
on the day of criterion the day when the
two armies met and Allah over all things
is competent.
So Allah
gets oneif of it
and Muhammad gets oneif of it and then
the rest goes to get spread out to
everybody else. Now let me ask you this
really quick. When it says that Allah
gets a fifth of the war booty,
h how is that how does that work?
Because Allah obviously isn't here on
earth collecting like trophies and coins
and clothes and stuff like that. So
where like where does that stuff go?
What do you
>> donations to the poor and needy?
>> But they already said this. They already
said Allah gets oneif of it. Then the
messenger also gets one fifth of it and
then the rest gets spread out to his
near relatives, orphans, needy traveler.
So what Allah gets is distinct from what
the needy gets and the traveler gets and
the relatives and the orphans.
So what you think
does that make sense what I'm saying?
You have Allah who gets his portion. He
gets oneif of it and the messenger gets
his portion and then the near relatives
get theirs of Muhammad. They get their
portion and then the orphans get theirs
and then the needy gets theirs and the
traveler gets theirs.
>> Yeah. It gets so for Allah would be what
Allah wants to happen with the money
which would be say donations zakat
things like that.
>> Interesting. So we have al Allah gets
one fifth, Muhammad gets one fifth
and then the rest get, you know, they
get the rest of the of the spread of the
uh of the bounty. So Muhammad gets more
of the bounty than anyone else.
>> Muhammad also donated a lot more than
anyone else.
>> Nah, brother. Come on now. Come on now.
Come on now.
This this this is the thing that I that
I'm saying we see in a lot of ways and I
could show you more but we see in a lot
of ways Muhammad benefits above everyone
else in Islam and this prophethood he
gets a lot of benefits. So this this
this narrative that Muhammad does not
benefit
um from he doesn't get any gain from
claiming to be a prophet of Allah, bro.
He he gained the world, man. Authority,
women, money, power, he got it all. And
he had special privileges above everyone
else.
special privileges.
You never see this with the other
prophets. You never see this with
Isaiah, King David, Solomon,
um Moses,
um a Abraham. You never see this with
anybody in the Bible. In the Bible,
there were no Everybody was under the
same covenant, under the same law. If
the prophet stepped out of line, if
Moses stepped out of line, he was
punished. Aaron the priest, if he
stepped out of line, he was punished.
David, if he stepped out of line, he was
punished.
Solomon, ridiculed, punished.
No, no special treatment. No. Oh, well,
yeah. uh for you, my beloved prophet and
king, you get to have as many women as
you want or you get a little bit more of
the war booty than everybody else or you
get to, you know, get with your adopted
son's ex-wife or, you know, no, none of
that. None of it
on King David. [laughter]
So, what are you thinking, man? What's
your thoughts?
Not sure right now. I ain't going to
lie.
>> That's That's fair. That's fair. What I
will say um is that you got to follow
the evidence where it where it leads,
brother. Got to follow the evidence
where it leads. If if the evidence is
demonstrating that Islam is obviously
false,
then got to drop it. If you're seeing
that the gospel is making sense and
Jesus is making sense, run to him. cling
to him, please. That's the best thing
you can ever do. The gospel is that
simple and easy.
Um, let me ask you this. What What is
keeping you in Islam? Like what what
what has convinced you that Islam is
true? Let's talk about that real quick
and see if we can rectify that.
I mean, the Quran's been pretty fairly
unchanged.
That's the biggest thing. Unchanged.
There's no corruption. There's no
contradictions that I've seen etc etc.
>> Okay. So presible has
>> preservation of the Quran and no
contradictions consistencies. Is that
right?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So when you say that the Quran has
been preserved
I want you to tell me
which one are you talking about?
You know those are just different
dialects, right?
>> Dialects?
>> Absolutely.
>> Uh, no, these aren't different dialects.
Which one of these has been perfectly
preserved
with no contradictions in it?
Help me out.
>> All of them.
Even if they say completely different
things.
>> They don't though. H the Quran is the
verbatim speech of Allah. Is that right?
>> Yeah.
>> Every word of Allah that has been spoken
in the Quran, it's there from day one.
Is that correct?
>> Not from very day one. It's been said
over time.
>> Right. Right. Right. What I mean is that
the very words that Allah has said in
the Quran
from the beginning has been the same. No
change
>> since it was
>> written down. Yes.
>> Since it was written down. Okay. So
these would be word for word, letter for
letter the same
>> in total. Yes. You might try and show
letters in the Arabic that are
different, but it's a it's a different
dialect,
>> right? But the word will be the same. It
might
>> it'll mean it'll have the same meaning.
>> Yeah.
>> The same have the same meaning. It'll be
the same word. Um it won't be a
different word. Is that right?
>> Same meaning.
>> I'm confused.
>> So there will be a different word.
>> Depends on what you're going to try and
do. Maybe.
So, it's either Allah said
yes
or he didn't say yes. You get what I'm
saying? Like,
>> yeah, he said yes,
>> right? So, none of these would have him
saying something else.
>> No.
>> Or not saying yes, right?
>> No, that's not going to happen.
>> Okay. All right. So, I'm going to show
you now. So, this is what I have here. I
have this is the Quran.
This is the wash Quran.
And this is the Huffs Quran.
Okay.
Colon Warsh Huffs.
>> Yep.
>> So, I'm going to bring them up on the
[snorts] internet and I'm going to show
you
I'm going to show you a difference.
Okay. To show you that the Quran, this
idea that it's word for word the same
verbatim speech of Allah
doesn't make sense. It doesn't hold.
You ready?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So, we're going to go to chapter
57. We're going to go to verse 24
in the hoffs.
Oops.
Verse 24 in the hoffs.
And it'll be verse 23 in the colon and
the wash.
All right.
All right, we can all see the screen.
Okay. Chapter 57, chapter of the iron,
verse 24. This is the hoffs. You can see
it.
>> Yep.
>> All right. Uh, do you read Arabic at
all?
>> I do not read Arabic.
>> Okay. It's okay. You won't need to for
this. This will be easy to see. So, you
see, do you at least recognize the word
Allah here?
>> Yep. Says Allah.
>> All right. And see that this word right
here is the word ha. It says Allah he is
and then it continues he is the I forget
what these words are but this is ha he
is. Okay.
Now when you go to the colon
the black Quran that I was holding up
and the wash the other blue one they
don't have that word there. It's
missing. You had the word Allah and the
and the ha is gone.
See, it's there in the in the huffs when
we go. It's gone in the colon and wash.
There's that gap.
>> Yeah, it's a dialect translation.
>> It's not a dialect or a translation.
This is Arabic.
>> You understand that there's different
dialects, right? In Arabic, it's very
different.
>> Dialects is how you speak, not how you
write.
In Arabic, it's very different because
there's here's an example. In Egyptian,
they can say a word, but it's completely
written completely different in Saudi
Arabia.
>> Correct.
>> It's written completely different.
>> Yeah. But there will be a word there,
right?
The word in Saudi Arabia and the word in
Egypt, there will be a word that they
say differently.
>> They can even write
>> things differently in total.
>> Yeah. But unfortunately
>> in every and can look completely
different.
>> But here's the problem. The problem is
is that there is no word to have a
different dialect on this. This word is
here in one Quran and gone in the other
Quran. So it's not a dialect difference.
There's this is a transmission
difference, a reading difference.
You get what I'm saying?
if the word was here and maybe you know
had I don't know
I don't know they they they pronounced
it differently that's fine but the word
would be there
that the word is gone brother from
another Quran the it doesn't exist in in
another Quran
that's a variant reading not a variant
dialect it's a variant reading
one Quran has the word
while the other Quran doesn't.
You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> So, the question would be which one did
Allah reveal? Did he reveal the one with
the Ha or did he reveal the one without
the Huah? Did he did Allah actually
because remember this is Allah's
verbatim speech. His eternal verbatim
speech that he revealed. Which one did
he reveal? Did he actually say this
whole sentence with the word included or
did he not?
Get what I'm saying? So this there the
Qurans are not word for word the same.
They are different.
And to
to point this out, this is a small
difference, brother. This isn't even a
big deal. This is a This is one of the
small examples.
This is one of the small examples.
>> Let's see a big one.
>> Oh, yeah. Sure. So,
I'll show you another one. Um,
I'mma use the Hadith since you can't
read Arabic. I'mma just I'mma use the
Hadith and show you what Aisha says. Is
that cool?
>> Cool.
>> Okay. Um, let's go to
let's go to sununa.com real quick
and let's let's do this right here.
Five sucklings.
Okay,
so watch this.
Uh, let's actually go let's find here it
is.
Sahi Muslim 1452a.
Sahi Muslim 1452A.
It says, "Aisha
reported that it had been revealed in
the Holy Quran
that 10 clear sucklings make the
marriage unlawful."
Then it was abregated
by five sucklings.
Right. So we Okay, it was the 10
sucklings was changed to five. No
problem. That happens, right? Abregation
happens. No problem. So, it was
abregated by five sucklings and Allah's
apostle died and it was before that
time. So, before he died, it was found
in the holy Quran and recited by the
Muslims.
So the five sucklings was in the Quran
before Muhammad died
of uh talking about what makes the words
the verse uh marriage unlawful.
However,
this does not exist in the Quran today.
You will you can't find this in no
Qurans. Five sucklings that make a
marriage unlawful. That verse does not
exist.
So back in Aisha's time in her Qurans in
their Qurans that existed back then they
used to have a verse that's talked about
the five clear sucklings. Now for
context guys five sucklings.
Five sucklings is um
is is talking about um making a marriage
unlawful. Meaning if uh let's say two
let's say a man and a woman were suckled
by the same woman
then they can't get married later on
even if they're not blood they're not
family but if they get suckled by the
same woman then they uh they cannot get
married. Okay.
Now, this can go on to even suckle grown
men. Like a a woman can suckle a grown
man just to make a marriage unlawful. If
you guys don't believe me,
there's a hadith about that. Okay, watch
this.
[sighs]
Let's see here.
So, I'll go ahead. You with me so far?
Uh, disagree? I'm with you. Okay,
let's see. [sighs]
Let's see. Let's see.
I put in the word specifically, man.
Give me the one.
No, that ain't it.
That's not it.
What's what's that hadith guys about the
uh does anybody remember that one?
Ah, I only know these words. Suckle him
for his groom.
Remember when Muhammad told told the
girl who's complaining to him to suckle
the the grown man? Are you got the
reference?
It's Bkari 2052.
All right, I'mma trust you. 100
side 1453A.
Really?
Hold on. I think this came up.
All right, let's see.
1453A.
Huh?
Yep. This is one. All right. So, Aisha
reported that Saha bent Sahel came to
Allah's apostle and said, so Saha is a
woman guys. She came to Allah's apostle
and said, "Messenger of Allah, I see on
the face of Abu Huda, signs of disgust
on entering of Salem, who was an ally
into our house." So her husband used to
get upset when she would see this man
enter this house, into their house,
whereupon Allah's apostle said, "Suckle
him."
Not her husband. Suckle Saleem, the guy
who keeps coming over, so that the
husband could feel comfortable.
She said, "How can I suckle him as he is
a grownup man?"
Allah's messenger smiled and said, "I
already know that he is a young man."
Omar has made this addition in his
narration that he participated in the
battle of Badr. And in the narration of
Iban Umar,
the words uh were Allah's messenger
laughed. So he laughed at it. He smiled.
He laughed and said, "Yeah, I know. I
know he's grown. You're a young man, but
do it anyway.
Circle him.
This is uh
some interesting interesting stuff that
Muhammad is telling people to do. What
What do you think about this so far? Uh
bro, [sighs and gasps]
you think this is there's there's hikma
in this? There's wisdom in this, bro.
Not in my brain. Not in mine either,
man. Not in mine either.
So, we have the suckling verses that are
missing in the Quran today. We have
words that are missing in the Qurans
today. Different ones, right? Uh depends
on which Quran you're you're reading. If
you're using Worsh, then you would say
Huffs added a word. If you're using
Huffs, you would say Warsh is missing a
word with the with the um example we
showed earlier. So this idea that the
Qurans were perfectly preserved and word
for word the same, brother, that is a
myth, man. That is one of the biggest
myths of all time.
Of all time.
Okay.
You want to see a contradiction in the
Quran?
>> In the Quran itself?
>> Yeah.
>> Let's see it. I'm curious about that
one. I haven't seen anything. I've read
the full book. You read the full book.
No contradictions.
>> Nope.
>> All right. All right. All right. All
right. We gonna put that to the test
today. All right.
We're going to put that to the test.
Okay.
Watch this.
I trust you're going to be honest.
You've been honest with me so far. So, I
trust you're still going to be honest
here. You're very reasonable. So, don't
change on me. Don't switch up on me now.
All right.
>> All right.
Okay.
[sighs]
Here's this verse. It's chapter 12 verse
111.
It says, "There was certainly in their
stories a lesson for those of
understanding. Never was the Quran a
narration invented, but a confirmation
of what was before it and a detailed
explanation of all things and guidance
and mercy for people who believe.
So this just gave us a few descriptions
about the Quran that it's a confirm it's
not a narration invented. It's not made
up. It's a confirmation of what came
before it.
It's a detailed explanation of all
things. It's a guidance and it's a mercy
for people who believe.
What we're going to be focusing on is
this detail right here. This quality
that it's a detailed explanation of all
things.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Now, watch this. This is the
contradictory verse.
Remember, it said it's a detailed
explanation of all things.
All right. Let me actually do it this
way.
Let me share my full screen so we can
look at these side by side.
All right.
So this is chapter 3:7.
It says, "It is he who has sent down to
you, oh Muhammad, the book. In it are
verses that are precise.
They are the foundation of the book and
others
unspecific.
As for those whose hearts is deviation,
they will follow that which is
unspecific,
seeking discord and seeking an
interpretation.
And no one knows its true interpretation
except Allah.
But those firm in knowledge say, "We
believe in it. All of it is from our
Lord." and no one will be reminded
except those of understanding. Okay, so
this verse says that there are verses
that are precise, right? They're pretty
clear. And then there are verses that
are unspecific. They're not clear.
They're not explained.
Right.
>> Right.
>> And that only Allah knows the meanings
of these unspecific verses.
This over here says that the Quran is a
detailed explanation of everything.
It's a detailed explanation of all
things.
So, it can't be a detailed explanation
of all things while also having
unspecific verses in in the Quran.
Verses that are not explained or
detailed.
That's a contradiction.
And
>> how do you ask how do you answer the
contradictions in the Bible?
Whoa, [laughter]
that's quite the jump, bro.
>> It's not that big of a jump. You
wouldn't say there's contradictions to
the Quran, which there are, but there's
also contradictions in the Bible, too.
It's not that big of a jump.
>> Okay. So, well, if you're acknowledging
that there are contradictions in the in
the Quran, then you're right.
>> There's a specific one.
>> Okay. So, you see the contradiction
then, right? I see it. It's in my face.
[laughter]
[gasps]
>> Okay. There are no contradictions in the
Bible which we can talk about as well.
But let me show you this. This is why
this is important.
It says if we go to chapter 4:82,
it says this, "Then do they not reflect
upon the Quran? If it had been from
other than Allah, they would have found
within it much contradiction.
According to the Quran's own standards,
if you find contradictions in the Quran,
it's not from God.
So is it fair for us who are thinking
people who know how to read and have
reading comprehension
that because we clearly see a
contradiction in the Quran and there's
others I can show but all we needed to
do is show one because there's
contradictions in the Quran by the
Quran's own standard the Quran can't be
from God. We agree?
>> Yeah.
So why are you still a Muslim then?
This is the last of the prayer of
visions and
I believe that Jesus is a prophet of
some kind at least and so I've went to
there because the Bible doesn't make
much sense to me because of various
things.
>> Well, I'm talking about as for now.
Right now
you've learned things and seen things
that you have not seen before the live
stream. You've seen things about Jesus,
about um his sacrifice and all that.
Things that you were not aware of prior
to this conversation. You know, you've
seen things in Islam with the Qurans and
the Hadith, the contradictions which you
were not aware of before.
So why are you still a Muslim now
after we've seen that the Quran can't
possibly be from from God by its own
standard? Are you still going to be a
Muslim?
>> I don't know.
>> You don't know?
How you not know? The the we the Quran
clearly can't be from Allah. Islam is
false. There's no reason to hold on to
it.
It's false. Right
now, that that definitely still leaves
leads you, you know, leaves you like,
okay, then what is the truth? That's the
next step. The first step is letting go
of the falsehood.
When you know it's false, let it go and
try to find the truth.
You feel what I'm saying? Sure.
>> So my question for you is, are you still
going to be a Muslim after knowing it's
false?
>> Can't do that.
Can't do that. [snorts] So Islam's done
and over with. Islam is done and over
with. But you're still
you're still in the abyss. You believe
Jesus is a prophet of some kind. That's
good.
You believe that there's one God. That's
good. Excellent. You're close. With the
walls of Islam out of the way, you
seeing that that's clearly false. What
is What then is the truth about Jesus?
What's the truth about his word? The
truth is, as we were seeing showing
earlier, bro, Jesus is more than just a
prophet. He's not a mere prophet. He's
God in the flesh.
That's the only way
that he was able to give his life for
all of us, mankind, past, present, and
future. That's the only way he can say
things like, "No one can take my life
from me. I lay my own life down and I
take it back up again on my own
authority."
No mere prophet can say that, can they?
>> No other prophet can say that.
>> No mere prophet can say that. No mere
prophet can say that. Matter of fact,
let me show you something else Jesus
says. And you tell me if a mere prophet
can say this.
You You tell me if a mere prophet can
say this.
Here we go.
Watch this.
Can a mere prophet say this? John
chapter 10 verse 28. Let me actually
take this down and put this back. We're
done with the Quran. We don't need it
anymore.
My sheep hear my voice. I know them and
they follow me.
I give them eternal life and they will
never perish and no one will snatch them
out of my hand. Can a mere prophet say
this?
>> Nope.
H
that the sheep belong to him. The people
they belong to him. How we follow him.
How we are in his hand and none can
snatch us out of his hand. How he's the
one who gives us eternal life. You let
me know, brother. Who's the one who
gives eternal life?
>> God.
>> So who is Jesus claiming to be?
Who's he claiming to be?
>> We've already agreed that I agree that
Jesus does say he's God in the Bible.
>> Absolutely.
>> I've already agreed on that.
>> That's right. [snorts]
So,
with Jesus demonstrating that he is more
than a mere prophet, he's God in the
flesh
who came to die for our sins, that there
is no forgiveness of sins without him.
This is what he says as well.
super important.
Three,
let's do uh 1618.
Pretty sure you've seen these verses
before. It's very important though.
This is what Jesus says about his
father. He says, "For God so loved the
world that he gave his only son
that whoever believes in him should not
perish but have eternal life.
For God did not send his son into the
world to condemn the world, but in order
that the world might be saved through
him. Whoever believes in him is not
condemned, but whoever does not believe
is condemned already because he has not
believed in the name of the only son of
God.
This is the gospel.
You believe in him as the son of God.
You trust in him for your salvation and
he saves you. You have eternal life. You
reject him and continue to reject him,
then you're condemned already.
You're condemned already.
>> I do have a strong question for you.
That's what No. So, we're reading John
right now. How do we know that John
actually wrote this and not a Roman, for
example, trying to
do whatever whatever benefits him, I
guess? Well,
>> because John didn't none of the authors
of the New Testament put their names on
the books. We don't know who actually
wrote it.
>> Yeah, we
>> we have church history that confirms
that for us. So, we have when I say
church history, the disciples had
disciples and they had disciples and and
so on and so forth. So um you have the
church fathers and the church bishops
who knew John and knew the apostles
learned under them. They continued their
traditions. And so when you look in
church history, bro, you'll never see
any disagreement on who authored the
gospels. Every single time it's the
same. Whether you're reading from
Papius, whether you're reading from
Clement, whether you're reading from any
of them, they all say Ernaaus, all of
them say Matthew wrote Matthew, Luke
wrote Luke, John and Mark at the
dictation of Peter. So all of them are
in 100% agreement. There's never ever
there's never any discrepancy in the
early church about uh the gospels.
This stuff comes later.
these this hypers skepticism.
Not only that, John demonstrates that he
has intimate Jewish knowledge that a a
typical Roman or Greek [clears throat]
wouldn't have. He's very in tune with
the Hebrew scriptures and the Hebrew
customs
um in a ways that a foreigner wouldn't
be. You get what I'm saying? So, we
don't have any reason to believe that
John uh was actually written by some
Roman conspirator and hijacker.
[snorts] Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, a little bit.
>> So, um yeah, you you can look into it,
man. You can look into it. Look, IP over
here. Hit me up. You can look into it.
We have guys like Erynaeus, Tertullian,
Clement of Alexandria, origin,
early church writers, early church
fathers, whether they're fathers or just
early church historians and writers,
they all agree that John wrote John.
So, um,
we have we have we we have confidence in
what we have. We have confidence in what
we have.
And so I'll uh I'll share this with you,
man. And then I don't want to just
overload you with stuff, you feel me?
I'll you know, I'll let you let you
think on things and um
you know, cuz this is this is huge and
it's very important. So I want you to be
able to think about this with a clear
mind and continue to listen or watch or
research whatever you want to research.
Right? I'll um I'll let you have that
that time, but watch what watch what
Jesus says in these verses. I'll leave
you with this. [snorts] He says,
talking to his disciples, cuz he's about
to go away. This is before his
crucifixion. He says, "Let not your
hearts be troubled.
Let not your hearts be troubled.
Believe in God. Believe also in me.
In my father's house are many rooms. If
it were not so, would I have told you
that I go to prepare a place for you?
And if I go and prepare a place for you,
I will come again and will take you to
myself that where I am, you may you may
be also
and you know the way to where I am
going. So this is what Jesus guarantees
us. If we accept him, if we believe in
him and we trust in him, he guarantees
that he's going to come to us and going
to take us to where he is. going to take
us to himself to be in his father's
house in heaven
with salvation and eternal life. This is
his guarantee to us.
He says, "And you know the way to where
I am going." Thomas said to him, "Lord,
we do not know where you are going. How
can we know the way?" And Jesus said to
him, "I am the way and the truth and the
life. No one comes to the father except
through me.
So
he encourages us to believe in him, to
trust in him, to cling to him. He's the
only way. He's the truth. He is the
life. There's no truth outside of him.
There's no life outside of him. Outside
of him, we are dead. We're spiritually
dead and we are doomed. We will perish.
But in him, we have life. With in him we
have truth and confidence and with him
we have guidance. He is the way. He is
the guide. He's the path.
So
I think on this man
consider the gospel. Um, if you have any
questions now, you can ask them now. Or
if you just want to sit on this and take
your time, you can uh you can do that.
And um you can come back and on any of
my live streams. It doesn't matter what
the topic is, you can come back and we
can continue talking. Okay.
>> I only have to continue much more to be
honest, man. I've studied all this and
you know
>> I no I don't know [laughter] what what
do you
>> I don't know man
>> what do you mean you you said you don't
need to you don't really need to
continue you study this what what is
what what do you mean
>> I mean I just studied all this and you
know brings me back to where I
originally was before I started bringing
on Muslim friends into my life
>> that's kind
You know, I'm kind of just back to
square one now. I don't think I'll need
to,
you know, I don't think I need to
>> What? What is that? What is that square
one? What? What is that?
>> I used to be a Christian. I've put a lot
on the line to become Muslim, but
>> Oh, I see.
So, you left you left Christianity and
joined Islam.
And then now you're saying that this
puts you back back with Christianity. It
puts you back with Christ.
I
>> think so.
>> Praise God.
Praise God.
This is uh this is huge, man, because
you know um h how old how old were you
when you became a Muslim?
>> Uh 15 16.
>> 15 16. And how old are you now?
>> 17.
>> Wow. Still young, bro. You're young.
You're this young and you're doing this.
This is incredible. So, look. Um,
it's it's pretty clear that you like
you're inquisitive. You look into
things. That's what you have shown and
that's what you said. Um,
I would tell you
to in this time when you're coming back
to Christ
to really really hold on to him, bro.
Really hold on to him. There are answers
to the questions or the doubts that you
have, bro.
And it's okay.
Just because you have a doubt or or if
you run into a question that seems
difficult and like there's no answer,
there is an answer. And God's got us,
right? In Isaiah chapter 1, he God
literally says, "Come, let us reason
together. Don't abandon God. Come and
reason with him. Put your cares and your
doubts to him. Say, "Show me what what's
the evidence of this? Help help me out
in this area."
Don't uh what what what's this um
what what's that uh parable guys where
the gospel
land is like a seed and lands on good
ground or or a person receives the
gospel and then the winds come and he
leaves or um you know it gives different
scenarios of a person who has received
the gospel.
You guys know what what I'm talking
about. What's that parable man? Is it
Mark 4?
Let me see.
Mark 4. Yeah. The parable of the sword.
Yep. This is it. Can I read Can I read
you this really quick? Cuz this is
>> Yeah, I got that.
>> All right. For sure. Look at this, bro.
This is Mark chapter 4, right? It says
verse, we'll start at verse uh three.
Jesus saying, he says, "Listen, behold,
a swer went out to sew, and as he sowed,
some seed fell along the path,
and the birds came and devoured it.
Other seed fell on rocky ground, where
it did not have much soil, and
immediately it sprang up since it had no
depth of soil. And when the sun rose, it
was scorched. And since it had no root,
it withered away. This is important. Had
no root, it withered away.
Other seed fell among thorns, and the
thorns grew up and choked it, and it
yielded no grain. And other seeds fell
into good soil, and produced grain,
growing up and increasing, and yielding
30fold, and 60fold, and 100fold. And he
said, "He who hears, let he who has ears
to hear, let him hear."
So then he breaks it down
and he said to them, "Do you not
understand the parable?
The swer sws the word." Right? So the
seed is the word, the message, the
gospel.
And these are the ones along the path
where the word is sown. When they hear,
Satan immediately comes and takes away
the word that is sown in in them. Those
were the birds that came and immediately
took away the seed.
So, Satan immediately comes and takes
away the word that is sown in them.
And these are the ones sown on rocky
ground. The ones who when they hear the
word immediately receive it with joy.
And they have no root in themselves.
They have no foundation but endure for a
while. But when tribulation or
persecution arises on account of the
word, on account of the gospel,
immediately they fall away.
So they receive the word with joy.
Troubles come, persecution comes,
confusion comes, and so they fall away
as a result.
And others are the ones sown among
thorns. They are those who hear the
word, but the cares of the world and the
deceitfulness of riches and the desires
of other things enter in and choke the
word, and it proves unfruitful. But
those that were sown on good soil are
the ones who hear the word and accept it
and bear fruit 30fold and 60fold and
100fold.
So notice this. It gives different
scenarios of people who receive the
gospel, who receive the truth. Some have
it swept away immediately by Satan. Some
receive it with joy. But when troubles
come, they give up and abandon Jesus and
abandon the word.
That was you. You as a Christian
got hit with I don't know was maybe a
dawa script and some confusions.
Abandoned Jesus, embraced Islam, a
falsehood for a false idol and a false
god.
This time around,
bro, is what I'm saying. This time
around, don't be the one who has no root
in them. The seed that has no root and
can't grow, can't flourish. Don't be the
one who is has the seed, you receive it
joyfully, but stuff happens and you give
up and abandon the gospel. Be those that
are sown on good soil.
The ones who hear the word and accept it
and bear fruit 30fold, 60fold, and
100fold. Let God use you as you're
supposed to be used.
Okay. You got another chance.
You say you call it square one. I don't
I don't think that this you're back at
square one. I think this is a whole new
a whole new role, bro. This is different
because now you are actually more
knowledgeable. Now you're more equipped
than you were when you were 15 and 14
and 16.
You understand what I'm saying?
>> Yes.
>> Amen, brother. So you renounced Islam
earlier.
You renounced Islam earlier. You accept
Christ again as your Lord and Savior,
bro.
>> Yeah.
>> Praise God, man. Praise God. Welcome
back, man. [laughter]
Welcome back, dude.
Welcome back.
Stay rooted, man. Do you uh do you uh
have a church near you?
>> I'm in Texas. I got churches all over.
>> Oh, yeah. You're in tough. Absolutely.
[laughter]
You're all over. In fact, it's crazy.
I'm going to be in Texas. Uh well, I
don't know what part of Texas you're I'm
going to be in Dallas. Are you near
Dallas?
>> Oh, no. I'm central Texas.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, I'm I'm
gonna be in Dallas uh February 6th. I'll
be debating a Muslim on the Islamic
dilemma. That's going to be fun. We'll
be in person debating. Uh I was going to
say, man, if you're close, you you
should come through. But you're
>> far from me.
>> Yeah, it's all good. It's all good. But
man, um God bless you, bro. God bless
you for being reasonable, being honest,
and following the truth where it led.
And it led straight to Christ. Don't let
him go again. Hang on to him this time.
Okay.
>> All right.
>> All right, bro. Uh, if you um Yeah, f
get with a church, brother. Get with a
church and go get baptized. Get baptized
and, you know, be raised up a new, man.
Be raised up a new. You already been
made a new inside. Be raised up a new
publicly and outwardly. Get baptized.
Okay. And um,
>> see, what kind of church should I go to,
though?
>> [clears throat]
>> Um, well, make sure you go to find a
church that's that's really teaching,
but that's biblically sound. Got to be
biblically sound. Um,
you know, uh, always like, it doesn't
matter what church you're going to,
always make sure that you are
double-checking
what the preacher is saying and stuff
like that. You're always you're you're
in your studies as well. Don't just
blindly follow just a preacher or pastor
or whatever. Go go go go go to So if you
find a Baptist church, biblically sound
Baptist church, that's perfectly fine.
>> Find you a good church that's preaching
the Bible, that's sticking with
scripture as their foundation.
Okay. Start start with there. Bible is
your foundation.
>> All right.
>> Yep.
>> All right. God bless you, man. If you
need me, bro, if you need me, hit me up.
I got I got my email. we can exchange
contacts and um we can stay connected
and stay in touch. All right.
>> All right.
>> All right. God bless you, man.
>> God bless you, too.
>> Woo. Cool, cool, cool.
So, that was a young brother there, man.
and uh
renounced Islam,
accepted Christ yet again,
accepted the truth in front of 5,000
people.
Praise God, man. God is good. All the
glory is yours, Lord. This is why we do
this, ladies and gentlemen. This is why
we are here day in and day out. don't
know what we're gonna get but we you
know God is going to bring those who he
is cultivating
right he's going to work in them man we
all we have to do is obey that's it all
we have to do is obey that is all we
have to do we have just got another
brother back we got another bra another
brother back from the darkness of Satan
from the bonds of Islam and uh man it's
no there's no greater feeling no greater
Gater feeling,
no greater feeling than doing the Lord's
will and his work.
Wow. All right. Exactly. The prodigal
son. He was a prodigal son. a prodical
son and came back home.